THEY WERE WINNING STANLEY CUPS.
GETTING READY TO START ALL THE
BACK ON NOVEMBER 20th.
IT WAS
>> Tripp: WHAT A WAY TO START.
AND YOU NG A GREAT SAVE.
I THINK THAT WAS A REALLY
CHALLENGE.
BY COACH TODD McLELLAN.
AND IF YOU ARE EARLY IN THE
JESPERI KOTKANIS BEEN GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY.
WITH EVERYTHING IT HAS GONE ON
AND HAS TAKEN FULL ADVANTAGE.
>> Mike: HE WAS LIVIIT BACK BEH
TO
>> Mike: C.J.
SMITH MAKI
>> Mike: AND HOPING FOR A QUICK
RECOVERY FOR ALL PLAYERS.
TESTING POANDERSEN DID A GREAT
JOB.
WITH A STRONG .  ETHAN BEAR HAS
OVER HIS STICK.
AND FOLLOWING PRESSURETERAVAINE-
UP OPPORTUNITY.
IT WILL BE KNOCKED AWAY.
A GOLOOSE
HOCKEY PUCK.
HE WILL SKATE IT AWAYCONTINUE.
MART GETTING IT BACK
UP TOP TO
BRETT PESCE.
LIKE HE
BACK TO SEAN DURZI.
ANAN
>> Referee:POINT TO
TONY DeANGELO.
VINCENT TROCHECK BACK  TO TONY
LEMIEUX.
AND RIGHT INTO THE CORNER.
LOOKING TO CLEAR, ETHAN BEAR.
FASTAT THE
OTHER AND.
>> Mike: JACK
>> Tripp:AWAY.
5:35
FROM JACCOB SLAVIN .  STEFAN
NOESEN.
AND